[موسيقى]
لذلك أريدك فقط أن تنظر حولك وأن تنظر
إلى الشخص الذي على يمينك وتنظر
إلى الشخص الموجود على يسارك ،
هل تعتقد أنه يمكنك قول كل ما
يدور في أذهانهم بالطريقة التي
يبدو أنها ليست وجهة نظري على الأرجح  الكلمات
قوية حقًا للتعبير عن التواصل
وقول كل ما يدور في ذهنك وأنا
أميل إلى استخدام كلماتي لكتابة بعض القصائد
التي بدأت مؤخرًا في التعبير عن
مشاعري وأفكاري من خلال
قصائدي والأشخاص
المحيطين بي لذا قرأت اليوم اثنين  من
قصائدي التي كتبتها ، واحدة عن
والدتي الجميلة والأخرى التي
قرأتها قبل
أن أشرحها قبل أن أعيد تشغيلها كانت من
أجلها الثرثرة من هاواي باسم يوسف
كاناكا مول لاركن ،
تعال إلى منزلها التاسع ، فهذا يعني
وتحير الأسقف طبقة الكاحل aschoff  Laham
hi Buffy group الآن a la CIMA Shan haha
ha Buffy group الآن للأسف صورة وكيف أن
jimana حمام شافى متحرر - لقد أتيت
لكح ليس فتاتنا الحكيمة Burnaby لدينا
الشهرية ولكن معلمها بهاي كريستوفر
يطلب أموالي  ime وأمل
الله العربية المؤقتة - الله سيترك مادن
لها تستقبلني بوب جاججا جاججا جاجا
متقلب السقف لذا كانت تلك أول قصيدة
لي عن أمي قصيدتي الثانية عن
الأشخاص الذين قابلتهم في
حياتي كصديق يخون ثقتك
ومثل الشخص الذي حولك من
أجل مصلحتهم وآمل أن يعجبك ذلك
نعم كاثرين أوز ليتا سيميون - يمارس الجنس
مع هارييت أحد الخصي عبر كاثرين أوز
لو ناقلة أوما سقف العضلات السحيقة يا
جونيك بدون لينا ثلاثة عشر في Essen
achhi carajás unik young  باتمان روسيني
مع الصم المائل ولكن بفرح البحث عن
المعلم
مارتا سونيك الذكر على بعض أسنان جزر الباهاما
مع كعكة يمكن أن يقتل وحشتي في الظهيرة
L am هو منزلنا وحدنا ، فهل
ستولد ماماس AB واضحًا ومحيرًا بشار
homie ترك المتصل المزمن آه  أنت
لا تنظر إلى اللعنة في وقت سابق ،
يعني قتل الله بينما هو
مخصي إيانتو حزمة كبيرة إيدينيا ، يمكنك تدمير
صحيفة عربية يومية سوف تسمع الخصي الحزين
تيم المعمودية ناما المتاعب وقاعدة أبي الشفاه
المظلمة الله لديه  منشط الزغابات المشيمية
قبل كل شيء سيارة يقودها
رونك رونيك عشوائي وضع أورورا على
اللغة العربية بعض الآثار على ابن عم موكوبا هي
قضية ماهينا هاليلو التي ماتت في المنزل
هاتف يوكا لا أستطيع أن أشكرك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]